[MUSIC]
>> Two years ago on her birthday, a friend
shared something I will ever forget.
For her privacy, I'll call her Ema.
Ema shared, I'm incredibly blessed and
thankful to have made it to 30 years old.
I don't know much about my kidney donor,
except for
his cause of death and that he and
I were the same age, 29.
No one prepares you for
the roller coaster of emotions,
of pure excitement and guilt you feel
when we're saving an organ donation.
Today on my birthday,
all I can do is pray for him.
I promise I will never forget
what a gift you have given me.
Organ donation is a tough topic.
Not only is it immensely personal,
but we have to talk about death.
Something very few of us like to
think about let alone discuss, but
we need to have more of
these conversations.
The more we can discuss death and
organ donation, the more likely we
are to register as donors and
it's imperative that we have more donors.
Over 115,000 people in America
are on transplant waitlists,
it is not a fun place to be.
Your health is deteriorating while
you're hoping for a donated organ.
Every time the phone rings,
there's a rush of adrenaline.
Is there finally an organ for me?
For thousands, time runs out
before that phone call comes.
What's shocking is that the likelihood
of getting that phone call and
receiving an organ transplant
vary significantly by region.
Organs are viable outside of the body for
only a short window of time.
So the organ donation
network is set up regionally.
When an organ becomes available,
it's offered to the person at the top
of the waitlist in that region.
This means people who live in areas
with lots of donors have a much
better chance at a new life than those
who live in areas with few donors.
Here in California, we have some of
the best hospitals in the world, but
it is not the best place if
you need an organ transplant.
Waitlists are some of
the longest in the country.
This is why Steve Jobs got his
liver transplant in Tennessee.
At the time, the waitlist for a liver
in Tennessee was under six months while
the national average was over a year and
some areas had waitlist over three years.
People are allowed to relocate,
to capitalize on shorter waitlists.
But very few people have the resources,
time or health to do so.
The vast majority are on the waitlist at
the transplant center closest to them.
In California and across the country,
we simply don't have enough
organs to meet the demand.
Less than 54% of us residents here in
California are registered as donors.
This is below the national average and
well below regions like Montana,
and Alaska where over 80% of
the population is registered.
Underlying these geographical
differences are differences by race and
recency of emigration.
Minorities and people who have emigrated
recently tend to donate less frequently.
So populations like
California that are more
heterogeneous tend to have
lower donation rates.
This is particularly concerning.
Because to get a transplant, you not only
to get to the top of the waitlist, but you
have to match with the donated organ based
on blood type, tissue biomarkers and size.
Many of these characteristics
are correlated to race.
So matches are much more likely to be
found within our own respective ethnic and
racial groups.
Our geographic and
racial communities need us.
By being an organ donor,
we have the opportunity to go on and
save up to eight people's lives.
These people might be a burn victim
who needs a skin transplant.
A neighbor with type one diabetes
who needs a kidney or pancreas, or
a classmate with a severe viral
infection who needs a new heart.
One act of generosity
can go a very long way.
As you consider being a donor, I'd
encourage you to have two conversations.
One with yourself and
one with your loved ones.
The conversation with yourself,
make sure your questions are answered.
Being an organ donor is an amazing
opportunity, but it can be on nerving.
And for many of us, the first time we
consider being an organ donor is at
the DMV of all places who
feels introspective and
charitable after waiting in line for
two hours.
>> [LAUGH]
>> When I was first brung the question
of being an organ donor at the DMV,
I checked the box, no.
At 17, I couldn't shake that doctors
wouldn't work as hard to save me if they
knew my organs could be used elsewhere.
I had yet to get the reassurance that the
priority of the healthcare system is to
save our lives whether we're donors or
not and
that the doctors treating us don't even
have access to the donor registry.
That's all managed by
an external nonprofit.
My situation was probably not unique.
We need to have these
conversations with ourselves on our
own time when we can get
the reassurances we need.
We can then go and register at the DMV or
online at organdonor.gov
I'm guessing many of you are wondering
why have this personal conversation now.
I'm young and
don't plan to die anytime soon.
I surely hope that's the case for
all of us in the room, but
I'd argue that it's a lot easier
to think about mortality now
when it feels a long way off and
to get comfortable with our decisions.
Being young gave me the opportunity
to reconsider my initial no.
And as of last year, makes me a proud yes.
The second conversation is
probably the tougher one.
The conversation with our
significant others and families.
If we're ever in a situation where our
organs can be donated, we'll be dying and
our families will be having one of
the toughest days of their lives.
We can make this a little bit easier on
them by clarifying our desires in advance.
This is incredibly important.
Hundreds of registered donors don't get
the opportunity to donate their organs,
because their families insist
otherwise at the hospital.
We need to prepare them to
make the decisions we want.
Similarly, let's ask them what
they want for themselves.
Let's ask them what questions they
have and help them answer them, and
make sure we are prepared to
facilitate their wishes if needed.
I find organ donation one
of the most humbling and
inspiring statements of human kindness.
One person giving the gift
of life to others like Ema.
I hope that we all have long and
healthy lives, but
unpredictable situations happen.
Have the conversation with yourself.
Have the conversation
with your loved ones and
let's step up, and
be there for our communities.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]